2 va-t-on rétablir le péage sur l'île
d'oléron ce péage existait jusqu'en 91
il était un peu plus de 100 francs et
les maires de l'île voudrait bien un
réel le rétablir pour limiter l'afflux
des voitures polémique françois privat
et bernard bonne à sa suppression en
1991 avait suscité la joie des touristes
et des habitants de l'île d'oléron
pourtant le péage du pont pourrait
prochainement être rétablie à la demande
des maires oléronnais qui estime que la
gratuité du pont entraîne la saturation
du réseau routier de l'île il ya des
problèmes de sécurité et de de
stationnement et ça devient très extrême
mans difficile et le gros problème c'est
les week-ends les week-ends pointe
nous avons beaucoup de gens qui viennent
sur l'île d'oléron pour pique [ __ ] on
a aussi des gros problèmes de nettoyage
et ça coûte très très cher à la
collectivité avant la disparition du
péage environ 15 mille voitures circuler
sur l'île quotidiennement durant les
mois d'été
aujourd'hui ce chiffre dépasse les 25
mille véhicules jour alors que les accès
aux villes et aux plages sont saturés
les touristes risquent de devoir acheter
leur tranquillité en étant à nouveau
accès à l'entrée de l'île ça freine
n'aura sûrement
beaucoup de personnes à venir la journée
et tout fait moi personnellement je
n'échangerais pas à l'état de payer
j'ai pas la ville via la région le parc
prépayé puisqu'ils ont échappé des
bombes
c'est revenez en moyen âge de remettre
des péages qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire quoi là ça veut dire que
les gens riches ont leurs hôtes facile
pour notre passé en 1991 de nombreux
commerçants espérant bénéficier d'un
afflux supplémentaire de clientèle
militer pour la gratuité du pont
aujourd'hui les avis ont bien changé les
gens viennent à la journée vont sur la
plage ne se prenaient même pas sur l'île
et au parc sans avoir ni consommé sur 10
min rien je pense que ce serait ce
serait une bonne chose
c'est une décision du conseil d'état qui
avait entraîné la suppression du péage
les responsables politiques locaux
devront trouver de solides arguments
pour obtenir le rétablissement d'une
taxe supérieur à 100 francs